say I'm going to come at this somewhat
ugly things along the lines I think that
model is already suggesting but I think
we might wind up very much in the same
place so so essentially I think it as
might have here to report some of our
relations of films work and the question
said it raises within and around the
field of architecture in urban studies
and urban history specifically with
respect to the common almost all the
cities of the Susan Walker sometimes
thinking
and came back with with a certain
historical specificity so I don't
presume that phenols work for his
politics are immediately translatable
into the terms of architectural Urban
Studies or in history mainly because
there are actually precious few attempts
to do so in any detail nor in the end
does phenomen self have very much to say
directly about the city per se
nevertheless my own conviction that such
translations remain critical for efforts
to understand and understand the urban
space and indeed the the geopolitical
violence about the retreat was speaking
all day at an aesthetical political as
well as an associate historical so as my
subtitle indicates up here this is
really only a preliminary report and i'm
meant to offer a point of departure for
further thought and research but there
is of course a good yield of little
crystal or comment on the architecture
urbanism the colonial and postcolonial
city but very little that connects the
city to the ontologies of violence of
which we can speak
and whether the Blessed as the urban
historian had the new king has suggested
much of this literature has indeed taken
inspiration directly or indirectly from
founds account in the Delhi double tap
of the colonial world as an apartheid
like quote world divided into
compartments may have blurted in Europe
in quarters of world come to
now tears coming to chill for all its
richness this burgeoning literature the
climate was modern city which also takes
in the contemporary global city that has
with with a few exceptions yet to
formulate truly generalizable hypotheses
regarding the fundamental violence of
asymmetrical racialized particle
compartmentalization this is especially
true when one tries to account for
compartmentalization in something like
aesthetic terms am i trying to say this
I say quickly in recognition of fennel
own attempts to discern the role played
by literary and artistic production the
in imagining decolonization and
constructing a national culture have
been inna for example in the concluding
pages of black skin white masks already
dismiss the hypothetical possibility of
quote a black literature or architecture
from the third century before Christ
sparse announcement any action
photography as was irrelevant to
transforming the lives of as he says the
present day child laborers in Martinique
he does not mention architecture in his
reflections in on a revolutionary in
post-revolutionary
poetics in the wretched of the earth
nevertheless there is a strong aesthetic
dimension
mm aught stronger perhaps than his
potent reflections on a national poetics
themselves may review so what I'm
calling aesthetic here takes the form of
an often perverse tortured synthesis of
psycho sensory experience and political
economic economic reality that is
captured most vividly I think in films
wrenching case studies of colonial or
mental disorders
yeah to it I will return to hint that
the implication that we just remind you
that in the vast literature on the
euro-american macoco the city of
industrial capitalism you will find time
and again verification of the theses on
the type of mental life of the
metropolis advanced by such writers as
similar to many mean and decreed
Krakauer to say nothing of himself in
architectural and art history such
arguments frequently extend into
accounts of the dialectic of destruction
and construction Ishi aided by the
modernist avant-garde in these familiar
accounts of the metropolis of balance
with neurasthenic strangers and
destructive fun of those both over and
lender stimulated by the abstractions of
the money economy and by the jarring
rhythms of mechanization but rarely is
metropolitan subjective experience
connected by historians to the physical
and psychological violence of planets
despite the fact that we're speaking of
cities like London and Paris
in other words it says that we have two
literature's on the modern city one on
Europe and
of course I'm schema Tizen maybe
unfairly but to illustrate I just want
to offer some some details on esoteric
historiographical skirmish concerning an
ephemeral that architectural a quite
significant episode and certain facts on
the ground so to speak in the history of
Algiers a city that we can take a
nigga's part are demonic for fennel in
they dominate air this is a again that
passed on their point order another 19
cent the episode is the story
story predates phenyls own algerian
period runs from stores runs from 1932
in the immediate aftermath colonial
centennial 1942 when the Vichy
government developed a revised plan for
the city's business district in civics
beginning in 1932 the Swiss French
architect shots at Washington Ave of
they're known as the trapezium designed
him unsolicited unsolicited set of five
master plans for Algiers the projects
which are now collectively at the time
the loose or exploding shells on other
in a sense perhaps internalization of
the everyday violence I'll try or I
everyday violence upon this planet
planet whose explicitly reproduced the
colonialist doctrine of a greater fracks
bound
yes so so this is what purchases yes for
the company is plenty see that what's up
that's what's connecting comparisons so
so so he reproduce on this municipal
project the Colonials doctrine of this
burger fax back together by the myself
trans Mediterranean access so this set
of projects were were followed in 1942
by a less ambitious six project known as
the design defect to commissioned by the
Vichy regime and in which the PCA by
that time was serving as a minor
official again in his own initiative he
was politically possible so the first of
this series back in 1932 which is what
we're going to talk about is the most
well known and has been widely
interpreted as emblematic attentions
that came to define the could be BCA's
post-war production such as that between
the tension between any division
as terrorists of modernism doing
geometrical or naturalistic formal
languages or between the authority of
the master plan construed as a poetic
statement and written growth the project
which will be presented to city
officials and in public exhibitions and
lectures was never realized and in fact
exerted little influence over the
novella development of the actual city
nevertheless its existence has
conditioned directly or indirectly
architectural accountant and discourse
on the modernity of colonial Algiers and
to begin with the vision proposes in the
project itself preserving the the whole
nearly the whole of the casbah while we
confront you can see it better here
you know you know he wants to preserve
the entire cause but while replacing
most of the French colonial district
which criticizes the plans starkly
geometric between this case up and down
the east-west axis reiterates the older
divine but now in vertically hovering
over the Kozma and in some sense
dominating it from above to connect a
new business center and the marine
quarter adapt to the heights of which
are dominated you see these the heights
are dominated by muscular curves Atwood
law housing in in counterpoint low down
them but see though viaducts of workers
health and surmounted by the highway
snake languidly along the coast
well I won't have any types comes with
both mouthing types consisting of Fred
works to be in field you see
for the needs abilities and tastes of
the the so that's the project yeah they
use directly the definitive account of
the planet's history remains backed by
my colleague God here on the government
Mary McLeod and her largely unpublished
PhD dissertation of 1985 and in an
earlier article in her dissertation
McLeod precedes that the history project
with a detailed study of the committee
is literally sympathies in France during
the 1930s which gravitated toward home
original cynical isms
dedicated to striking a balance between
technological modernization and local
traditions against this ideological
backdrop MacLeod interprets the project
synthesis of organic and geometrical
forms and its integration of the Kasbah
into a syncopated at the yet inherently
rational Roman system as evidence of
what she calls a commitment to the union
of two cultures consonant with the
position held at the time by
assimilationist algerian leaders in in
this reading the Kasbah figures an
organic vernacular that is
curvatures of the dominant meeting still
the project I've got the Kasbah as an
organic vernacular have done is echoed
in the curvature of the continuous bars
of housing which absorbed the supposedly
rationalizing force of the main axis
while imparting to it purportedly
Mediterranean lyricism though
meticulously documented and carefully
assembled in clouds analysis therefore
you would have recognized I think
reproduces certain tropes that have
since been identified as belonging to an
exotic odd is an Orientalist strain of
European modernism by for example of
opposing allegedly rational modern space
to allegedly organic or traditional
space that at least was the criticism
implicit that criticism was implicit to
me in the architectural and urban
historian Zenit relics 1992 rereading of
the boo-boos Isabelle chairs plan each
other mounts the new announced a nuance
boutique of Luigi as Orientalist
gendered stereotyping of eret of culture
while Jenny while gently noting McLeod's
relatively like gloss on French colonial
urbanism and its history is a subject to
which I show that as I continue to get
much trouble my colleagues here my
colleague Mendelian right has since
provided a broadly comparative
socio-historical cauchy's
conservatism though not specifically
with respect to Algiers but in terms of
the contested interpretation of this
project
telex real challenge is to the Italian
architectural historian montre don't
Authority who's influential neo-marxist
reading of the project in 1973 which
found entirely to mention the colonial
context has been an important point of
departure for reference out for others
so in that sense within the territory
this is kind of the point of phenomena
clarksville so genic is also the author
of a comprehensive architectural and
urban history of colonial the held years
that was 1997 there notably she
introduces her study with two
contrasting accounts of Algiers
illustrated by this part one bit
biphenyl in 1961 and another button to
be able that 20 years earlier the
passage from finals taken from a
celebrated chapter on violence in them
in town in which he describes quote a
settlers town as a strongly built town
on the other stone and steel brightly
click with
and even streets covered with asphalt on
which trade the settlers feet were
protected by strong shoes while in
striking contrast with phenom calls the
native town is a world without
spaciousness its inhabitants lived on
top of each other their huts are built
one on one on top of the other the
native town is hungry camp started to
breath meet with she was a cult of life
the native town is a touching village a
talent it needs a town while wallowing
in the mire to this chalak compares a
passage from the provision that's
associated with his own your plans for
the city so this is the vision in in
1932 sorry about 20 years of Portland
and I've seen from the sea Europe and
Algiers is nothing but crumbling walls
and devastated nature the whole subplot
the European work but what I can
contrast this with the Visio puts it the
casbah is both irrefutable and
consonance with nature because from
every house from the terrace and these
terraces add on to each other like a
magic and gigantic staircase descending
to the sea one sees the space the sea
so tell me the sentence in these two
excerpts - incompatible readings of the
colonial partitioning of Algiers well
the history that she outlines the actual
history of their development which
begins with the outset of French rule in
1830 and runs up to independence
demonstrates in vivid detail the stages
through which panels the divided world
was constructed in physical and social
space it's a later history of everyday
life that interweaves proportionally
realized master plans with an evolving
housing policy a general ideology of
domesticity and the construction of
regional infrastructures to which the
caduceus heroic plans are barely more
than an effective wall footnote so jelly
concludes her analysis on - the colonial
housing projects which occur just at the
end of her story known and the DiFonzo
Samba with a striking observation and
here's one
the striking observation that focuses
the knowledge to each other but the
overruling intention behind the housing
projects was to secure the French
presence furthermore construction
intensifies during the height of the
Algerian war between 1954 and 1962 the
French built more frantically than ever
and unprecedented quantities for local
populations
military action and large-scale
construction doesn't join forces in the
war against Algerians their conflicting
premises reinforced each other but also
display the dilemmas of France's
colonial policies ultimately the
ideological agenda behind construction
projects that proved ineffective as
housing complex after housing complex
turned into a center of resistance and
even a military confrontation thus
architecture becomes a site for the
enactment both of colonial violence and
of its armed resistance still when it's
left to wonder whether there's not also
an aesthetic or at least as I was saying
the psycho spatial dimension to this
that reaches beyond the stylistic or
ideological confrontation between
so-called modern and additional forms in
which these housing projects were caught
attention that is supposedly example but
exemplified by the disease
this returns me finally to charity
Manfredo to furries indifference to
colonialism in his reading of the plan
in this famous book planet is a very
influential text architecture in Utopia
of 1973 they are temporary sweepingly
content condemns the modernist
avant-garde swear their complicity with
an eventual marginalization by the
dialectic of design and capitalist
development is equal in which
architecture can only under a famously
both worn off anguish by the absorbing
in its causes though he was hardly a man
the anguish to for he had in mind was
that of a bourgeois intelligentsia
confronted with its own powerlessness to
redirect capitalist development his
argument reaches its climax when he
discerns in the caduceus Algiers plan a
put-on book presses of utopia this
question crisis is really a redundancy
we're in the utopian intellectual labor
of the architect becomes superstructure
thus for 240 architecture as ideology of
the plan is struct away by the reality
of the plan when the level of and the
level of utopia having been superseded
now then the plan becomes and offers
mechanism so my plan at Sephora means
not just the kind of master plans with
athletic O'Neill aircrafts which I've
been referring but rather the diverse
techniques developed by international
capital in its bid to manage the future
from Keynesian interventionism to
mid-century urban renewal to the Soviet
fiber but what was the actual plan for
health years such that the fluted music
a pseudo rationalization of the city's
infrastructures became redundant
pertinently found nearly in the
annexation of what two flurries
neo-marxist language called paleo
capitalist urban space into supposedly
organizations like the Roman samba
enacted by the colonial state as as
China and many others have shown the in
many different contexts the historical
books partitioning the formal space
combined dispossession with structural
racism in this respect the caduceus plan
for Algiers did not become redundant
when its proposal for resolving class
antinomies antinomies through separate
but equal forms of modernization was
overtaken by actual class produced by
some mythic technocracy it was redundant
from the start since it nearly
reproduced an impression upon the
asymmetrical racialized partitioning of
the city that was already well in place
by the early 1930s
but in a sense this is the hypothesis I
want to offer as a person form a
question what of this bourgeois anguish
of the European metropolis that the
flurry finds transposed onto Algiers
they know the busiest project here I can
only suggest that phenols case studies
of colonial war and mental disorders be
set beside Georg Simmel classic essay of
1903 the metropolis and mental life to
show that when we speak of both Paris
and Algiers as well as other
subjectivity z' they engender together
we are not speaking of like
communication and acknowledged aesthetic
codes but of a transparent Kamiel mental
life lived in the streets and in the
case of those militarized Franko
Algerian apartments in the bedrooms of
cities at war
cymbals CC's on metropolitan psychic
strand estrangement and the wider body
of social theory to which they belong
which have been informed so many
accounts of the European and North
American chocolates run aground I think
when confronted with a psycho sensory
world of colonial violence elucidated by
phenomena this is a world to which the
modern metropolis is nevertheless
irreducibly tethered at entering that
lives on indeed in today's global cities
and many other places we've got all the
descriptions of this world partition
inside and out have not been superseded
by nominees who preceded by now familiar
to Roy black poverty on the contrary
they remain capable of transforming our
understanding of both the colonial city
and the modern metropolis as well as of
their successors how then might
historical analysis as well as the
countess today's proliferating forms of
urban apartheid tomorrow agenda dog Lulu
God's term for French for about how how
might we sear off such lines its
inscription in space as well as on the
bodies and in the minds of and the body
answer as well as on the bodies and in
the minds the colonial and post-colonial
subjects since I am unable in the time
available even to approach this question
I prefer to allow fennel to have the
last word and in a slightly modified
translation on the internal schisms or
wartime mental disorders which belong to
a psycho spatial economy that defines
colonized and the colonizer a lot this
is again from the rich of the earth
through quote
the chatter
ecology of war but because it is a
systematic negation of the other person
and a furious determination to deny the
other person all attributes of humanity
colonialism forces the people that
dominates to ask themselves the question
constantly